This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、体能以及复原力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。那是数字 2（TWO）percent，在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在 Look Back at it 播客节目中。从1979年开始，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look back at it。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）带来的《用艰难的方式学习》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个空间探讨黑人男性的经历，进行真诚的对话，这些对话在其他任何地方进行其实并不安全，但你是在与一个懂行的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。这向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不。并不意味着你需要这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在 AHA 广播应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《用艰难的方式学习》。2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一个骗局。欧文斯女士，你篡改了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我篡改测试是一次。这需要大批网络侦探出动，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean.
迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于要承担后果了。在 iHeartRadio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》（The psychology of your 20s），这是一个探讨我们在二十岁时经历的一些重大生活变化和转变及其含义的播客。
for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode as we break down the psychology of your 20s.
关于我们的心理学。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到这个播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身处世界的哪个角落，很高兴你能来到这里，收听另一集节目，和我们一起剖析二十岁的心理学。
Today, we are diving into a topic. I think that hits close to home for so many of us, even if we don't always want to openly admit it or acknowledge it. honestly my inbox has been just like buzzing with requests for this episode. I think I get this at least five times a week. We are talking about the psychology of nicotine. And I definitely saw a rise in requests for this episode after we did our 20 biggest mistakes people make in their 20s episode. And we talked about smoking. And I had a lot of messages from people being like,
今天，我们要深入探讨一个话题。我认为这个话题与我们许多人的生活息息说相关，即使我们并不总是愿意公开承认或认可它。老实说，我的收件箱简直被要求制作这一集的请求刷屏了。我想我每周至少收到五次这样的请求。我们正在讨论尼古丁的心理学。在制作了“人们在二十岁时犯下的二十个最大错误”那一集之后，我绝对看到了对这一集请求的激增。我们谈论了吸烟。我收到了很多人的私信，他们说，
how come you've never done an episode on this? Well, guess what? There was one right around the corner. This is that episode. So nicotine is one of the world's favorite drugs. And it is in fact a drug. It is highly addictive. It is highly prevalent. Its usage is very prevalent. And the stuff it's packaged in makes it incredibly terrible for you. we know that vapes, that cigarettes, that nicotine pouches, they are not good for you, no matter how well the marketing might try and make them same. So why are so many of us, despite all of this knowledge, all the education we have now, still getting hooked? Well, I think there's quite a few interlinked reasons.
你怎么从来没做过关于这个的节目？好吧，你猜怎么着？节目马上就要推出了。这就是那一集。所以尼古丁是世界上最受欢迎的药物之一。它确实是一种药物。它极易让人上瘾。它非常普遍。它的使用非常普遍。而它包装在里面的东西使得它对你极其有害。我们知道电子烟、香烟、尼古丁袋对你都没有好处，无论营销怎么试图把它们说得天花乱坠。那么为什么我们当中有这么多人，尽管拥有所有这些知识，拥有我们现在所拥有的所有教育，仍然会深陷其中呢？嗯，我认为这背后有相当多相互关联的原因。
Obviously, the use of nicotine is absolutely not a new phenomenon. it has been used for so many years. It's also sometimes had medicinal purposes, and it's often synonymous with socializing, with stress relief, with status. I think particularly with vapes, even more so than cigarettes these days. They're super accessible, even at times affordable.
显然，尼古丁的使用绝对不是一种新现象。它已经被使用了这么多年。它有时也有药用价值，而且它通常是社交、压力缓解、地位的代名词。我认为特别是电子烟，如今比香烟更是如此。它们超级容易获得，有时甚至价格实惠。
You know, some stores do like multi-buy deals on them. They look enticing. There's this whole allure around smoking and nicotine, and they have colorful packages. and fruity flavors and, you know, it's not discreet. And these items, cigarettes, vapes, they become, like, deeply ingrained in social scenes. So that even if you've had all of this education, it still kind of seems like, well, if everyone else is doing it, well, then why don't I? It's like, oh, we're all hitched to the same wagon. We're all in the same boat. As long as
你知道，有些商店会对它们进行多件购买的优惠活动。它们看起来很诱惑。吸烟和尼古丁周围有一种整体的魅力，它们拥有色彩斑斓的包装。还有水果味的，而且，你知道的，它并不隐蔽。这些物品——香烟、电子烟——已经变得像深深融入社交场景中一样。以至于即使你接受了所有这些教育，它看起来仍然像是：好吧，如果其他人都在这么做，那为什么我不呢？这就像，哦，我们都绑在同一辆战车上。我们都在同一条船上。只要
they're going to face the same health consequences as me, well, I may as well be part of the in group or may as well be enjoying it. Also, nicotine just feels amazing. It just feels, it feels good. And so sometimes when you're in the moment and you're enjoying the cigarette or you're enjoying the hit, it's hard to think further down the line to when the other side of the coin flips over and when the other side of this habit comes and kind of bites you in the butt. It's something that I think we're like in the current moment we're not too great at acknowledging and also because of the fact that nicotine and smoking and vaping has had like a revival in recent years you know the snowball effect of more and more people doing it is making it more and more enticing it might be
他们将面临和我一样的健康后果，好吧，那我何妨也成为内部群体的一员，或者享受其中呢。另外，尼古丁的感觉就是太棒了。它只是感觉，感觉很好。所以有时当你身处当下，正在享受香烟或享受那一口带来的快感时，很难去长远地考虑当硬币的另一面翻转过来，当这种习惯的另一面袭来并反咬你一口的时候。我认为这是我们在当下并不太擅长承认的事情，而且由于尼古丁、吸烟和电子烟近年来有所复苏，你知道的，越来越多的人这样做产生的滚雪球效应让它变得越来越诱惑，这可能
not very surprising for you guys to hear but for the first time in decades we are seeing nicotine use rates shift significantly in younger populations um especially in Western countries for many, many years, the use of nicotine products was declining, and then suddenly there has been this massive increase. There have been studies in the UK, in the US that show e-cigarette usage, and nicotine uses is at the highest it has ever been, maybe, amongst 18 to 24-year-olds. So this isn't just a blip, this is something that I think we really need to investigate, but also not from a point of shame.
对你们来说并不是很令人惊讶，但几十年来我们第一次看到年轻人群体中的尼古丁使用率发生了显著变化，特别是在西方国家。很多很多年里，尼古丁产品的消费量一直在下降，然后突然之间出现了巨大的增长。英国和美国的研​​究表明，18至24岁人群的电子烟使用率和尼古丁使用率处于历史最高水平。所以这不仅仅是一个小插曲，这是我认为我们真正需要调查的事情，但也不是出于羞耻的角度。
not from a point of like, how dare you do this? How dare you poison your body? Like, you should know better. I don't think that's a healthier approach. Of course, we know better for a lot of things and we still do them and we still do them with things that are a lot less addictive than nicotine. Nicotine is such, like, it is truly like a miracle substance for our brain and it does such crazy, wild things to our neurochemistry, of course people are getting hooked. And of course there is a whole, there is a whole level of addiction around it that needs to be discussed. So we're going to approach this episode from a perspective of just like understanding, psychoeducation, knowledge, fun facts, interesting studies, so that you can kind of, yeah, just learn some more
不是出于一种诸如“你怎么敢这么做？你怎么敢毒害你的身体？就像，你应该更懂事才对”的角度。我认为这不是一种更健康的立场。当然，对于很多事情我们其实都懂，但我们还是会去做，而且我们对那些远不如尼古丁容易上瘾的东西也还是会这样做。尼古丁是如此的，它真的就像我们大脑的奇迹物质，它对我们的神经化学物质产生了如此疯狂、剧烈的影响，人们上瘾当然是理所当然的。当然，围绕它存在着一整套需要讨论的成瘾机制。所以我们将从理解、心理教育、知识、趣味事实、有趣研究的角度来探讨这一集，以便你可以，是的，学习更多知识。
and see how you might be able to get out of a nicotine addiction, how you might be able to help a friend, how you might be able to quit vaping once and for all, quit cigarettes, whatever your intention with this episode is, there is something for you. Without further ado, I'm very excited for this episode. I hope you learn a lot. I hope you're as intrigued as I am. Let's get into it. All right, so let's cut to the chase.
看看你如何能够摆脱尼古丁成瘾，如何能够帮助朋友，如何能够一劳永逸地戒掉电子烟、戒掉香烟，无论你听这一集的目的是什么，这里总有适合你的内容。闲话少说，我对这一集感到非常兴奋。希望你学到很多。希望你和我一样感兴趣。我们切入正题吧。好了，我们开门见山吧。
How does nicotine actually work its magic? Or maybe we should say it's mischief on your brain. Nicotine is a tiny, tiny molecule, but it's. It's incredibly powerful because it knows how to play perfectly with your brain's natural chemistry. And it's able to unlock all these different things in our brain that feel amazing. Nicotine is actually a naturally occurring substance. It is a nitrogen-containing alkaloid that is found in a tobacco plant at very high levels, but also in small doses and things like tomatoes, in potatoes, in eggplants, which you may.
尼古丁到底是如何发挥它的魔力的？或者也许我们应该说它对你的大脑施展了什么恶作剧？尼古丁是一个微乎其微的分子，但它却。它非常强大，因为它知道如何完美地与你大脑的自然化学成分配合。它能够解锁我们大脑中所有那些感觉妙不可言的不同事物。尼古丁实际上是一种天然存在的物质。它是一种含氮生物碱，在烟草植物中含量极高，但在西红柿、土豆和茄子等食物中也有小剂量存在，你可能。
may not know, but it's main, the main place that we extract it is from tobacco plants in the levels at which you're going to feel something in your body. So when it enters your body, it is quickly absorbed into your bloodstream and it zips straight through your brain. It is absorbed especially fast if you are smoking it because it's already in a form that your body doesn't need to metabolize. And once it's in your brain, which happens sometimes within, like literally nanoseconds, it activates your nicotinic receptors. Here's another fun fact. Even if you don't smoke, even if you have never touched a nicotine product in your life,
可能不知道，但它主要的、我们提取它的主要地方是烟草植物，其浓度能让你在体内感受到某种效果。因此，当它进入你的体内时，它会迅速被吸收到你的血液中，并直奔你的大脑。如果你是在吸烟，它的吸收速度会特别快，因为它的形态已经不需要你的身体进行代谢。一旦它进入你的大脑，这有时在几纳秒内就会发生，它就会激活你的尼古丁受体。这里还有一个趣事。即使你不抽烟，即使你这辈子从未碰过尼古丁产品，
you still have these receptors. Every single one of us has these receptors. So when nicotine, the product, the substance, the chemical binds to these receptors, it triggers the release of a whole cocktail of neurochemicals. you probably already know dopamine serotonin. We'll get into those in a second. But the main one is a neurotransminor called acetacoline, which is essential for voluntary muscle movements,
你仍然拥有这些受体。我们每一个人都拥有这些受体。因此，当尼古丁这种产品、这种物质、这种化学物质与这些受体结合时，它会触发一整套神经化学物质的释放。你可能已经知道多巴胺、血清素。我们一会儿就会讲到这些。但主要的神经递质是一种叫做乙酰胆碱的物质，它对自主肌肉运动至关重要，
but also for focus, which is why when you smoke, vape, whatever it is, you may immediately feel more alert, more in tune with your surroundings, and more concentrated on whatever is in front of you. It's why a lot of people in their 20s often get hooked to Nicky
但也对注意力至关重要，这就是为什么当你抽烟、抽电子烟或无论什么形式时，你可能会立即感到更警觉、与周围环境更合拍，并且更能集中精力于眼前的事物。这就是为什么许多二十多岁的人经常对尼古丁上瘾。
as a focus substance when they're studying or working. It's why a lot of people who work nights or are chefs or work those really intense, like, long-haul jobs also get addicted to this product because it does wonders for your brain. There's no denying that. The other star of the show is, of course, dopamine. Acidicoline is where I guess we notice the main influence on our. our attention and on our focus and on our mood, dopamine is what really hooks you. So when dopamine floods your brain's reward pathway, specifically the mesolimbic pathway, often called the brain's
将其作为学习或工作时的专注物质。这就是为什么许多上夜班的人、厨师或从事那些非常紧张、长期工作的人也会对这种产品上瘾，因为它对你的大脑有着奇妙的作用。这是不可否认的。节目的另一位明星当然是多巴胺。我想乙酰胆碱是我们注意到它对我们的主要影响的地方。我们的注意力、注意力和情绪，多巴胺才是真正让你上瘾的东西。因此，当多巴胺淹没你大脑的奖励通路，特别是中脑边缘通路（通常被称为大脑的）
pleasure circuit, it creates feelings of pleasure, satisfaction, even euphoria. And it's the same pathway that is activated by food, by sex, by drugs. So that hit you get from nicotine, when as soon as that enters your body and your brain begins to associate it with it with pleasurable feelings, it's just going to keep screaming, we want more of that. We want more good stuff. We want to feel better, feel more pleasure, more. Nicotine also influences norapinephrine, which again makes you feel more awake, more alert, more focused, and also glutamate, which after like the initial statured,
快乐回路，它会创造出快乐、满足甚至欣快感。这也是食物、性和药物所激活的相同通路。所以当你体内一旦进入尼古丁，你的大脑开始将其与快乐的感觉联系起来时，它就会一直尖叫，我们想要更多。我们想要更多好东西。我们想要感觉更好，体验更多的快乐。尼古丁还会影响去甲肾上腺素，这同样会让你感到更清醒、更警觉、更集中注意力，还有谷氨酸，它在经历最初的饱和、
stimulant effect will then have that counterbalance of GABA, which is going to bring you a sense of relaxation and reduced anxiety. All of this is happening happening very, very quickly. And the more you begin to associate the puff of a vape or the puff of a cigarette with that feeling, the more the biological mechanism of addiction begins to really take a hold. This is the biological trap of substances like nicotine. With repeated nicotine exposure, those brain receptors that we mentioned before, they also become desensitized. So after the initial, perhaps weeks or months, maybe even years of getting that same feeling of pleasure, depending on how often you're using it, they are going to stop responding as strongly to nicotine over time. And so to compensate,
兴奋效应之后，会产生GABA（γ-氨基丁酸）的抵消作用，从而给你带来放松感和降低焦虑感。这一切都发生得非常非常快。你越是开始把抽电子烟或抽香烟的吐雾动作与那种感觉联系起来，成瘾的生物学机制就越是开始真正占据主导地位。这就是像尼古丁这样的物质的生物学陷阱。随着反复接触尼古丁，我们之前提到的大脑受体也会变得不敏感。因此，在经历了最初的几周或几个月，甚至可能是几年的同等快乐感觉后，这取决于你使用的频率，随着时间的推移，它们对尼古丁的反应将不再那么强烈。为了弥补这一点，
your brain actually creates more of these receptors. This is a process known as upregulation, and it means that your brain now needs more nicotine to just feel normal or to achieve the same effects as you previously did. This is why I think it's so important that we understand the neurochemistry and the biology of addiction, because there is some wild stuff happening in our brain that we tend to ignore,
你的大脑实际上会产生更多这些受体。这个过程被称为上调，这意味着你的大脑现在需要更多的尼古丁才能感觉正常，或者达到与以前相同的效果。这就是为什么我认为理解神经化学和成瘾生物学如此重要，因为我们的大脑中正在发生一些疯狂的事情，而我们往往忽视了这一点，
and we put it all down to our discipline or to our morals or to our, I don't know, our sense of like agency when we're actually fighting an uphill battle against our brain's natural desire to experience more pleasure and to experience more dopamine. And here is a highly potent substance that does that for us. So then when nicotine levels drop, maybe it's been a couple hours since your last nicotine gum, whatever it is, those extra desensitized receptors, they are no longer being stimulated. And this imbalance is what creates really uncomfortable, physical and psychological withdrawal symptoms. So irritability, anxiety, difficulty concentrating, you get restlessness, like you get these cravings, even like sometimes, physical aches. And these symptoms are actually really unpleasant. And we know through this repeated
我们把这一切归咎于我们的纪律性、我们的道德，或者，我不知道，我们的自主意识，而实际上我们是在进行一场与大脑渴望获得更多快乐和更多多巴胺的自然欲望的逆水行舟。而这里正有一种高效能的物质能为我们做到这一点。因此，当尼古丁水平下降时，也许距离你嚼上一块尼古丁口香糖已经过去了好几个小时，无论是什么情况，那些额外变得不敏感的受体，它们不再受到刺激。而这种失衡正是产生真正令人不舒服的身体和心理戒断症状的原因。比如易怒、焦虑、难以集中注意力，你会感到不安，比如你会渴望，甚至有时会有身体上的疼痛。而这些症状其实真的很不愉快。我们通过这种重复的
learning process that the quickest way to alleviate them is just to go back to the product. It's just to introduce more nicotine. This desperate and in fact sometimes unacknowledged kind of behavioral loop really fuels our physical dependence and creates the compulsion and creates the addiction. So, you know, again, as amazingly adaptive as your brain is, your brain also actively adapts to a substance that is actually not that bad for you. Nicotine is not bad for you. It's what it comes in. And so you need more and more of it, which means that you ingest more and more of these terrible chemicals, terrible other substances that just like wear and tear your body, like not much else can do.
学习过程知道，缓解这些症状最快的方法就是回到产品本身。也就是引入更多的尼古丁。这种绝望的、事实上有时是不承认的行为循环，真正助长了我们的身体依赖性，并造成了强迫行为和成瘾。所以，再次说明，尽管你的大脑具有惊人的适应能力，但你的大脑也会主动适应一种对你实际上并没有那么好的物质。尼古丁对你没有坏处。坏的是它附带的东西。所以你需要越来越多的它，这意味着你摄入越来越多这些可怕的化学物质、可怕的其他物质，它们会像几乎没有其他东西能做到那样，对你的身体造成磨损。
Another part of this physical and psychological dependency or addiction is also stress. Stress plays a huge role because nicotine is a special kind of drug in that it is both a stimulant, meaning that it makes you happy and energetic but also a depressant, meaning that it calms down your nervous system. I'm sure you guys will have seen the trope on TV and in cinema of like the stressed out overworked character, lighting up a cigarette with a glass of wine at the end of the long day. I think it's pretty fair to say that we as a generation in this decade, those of us in our 20s, are a stressed out generation. We are very stressed. It's a time of so much change, so much
这种身体和心理依赖或成瘾的另一个部分也是压力。压力扮演着巨大的角色，因为尼古丁是一种特殊的药物，它既是一种兴奋剂，意味着它能让你快乐和充满活力，但同时也是一种抑制剂，意味着它能让你的神经系统平静下来。我确信你们在电视和电影中见过这样的老套情节：一个压力巨大、工作过度的角色，在漫长一天结束时点上一支烟，喝上一杯酒。我认为可以公平地说，我们这一代人在这十年里，也就是我们二十多岁的人，是一个压力重重的代际。我们压力很大。这是一个充满如此多变化的时期，有如此多的
upheaval, especially for like, again, for our generation who was dealing with a whole litany of things that previous generations didn't have to deal with. So it might be, you know, not that surprising that a lot of us actually go to nicotine as a perceived tool for emotional regulation. A 2019 study published in the journal Addiction Biology demonstrated this by looking at how stress messes with the brains of smokers and the results of this study were pretty illuminating and mind-blowing. Researchers gave some smokers in the study stress hormones to mimic a real-life stress response, then they asked them to go into an MRI scanner and to do a memory task. Normally, the part of the brain that helps with self-control, your prefrontal cortex, would light
动荡，特别是对于像我们这样不得不应对前几代人不必应对的一连串事情的这一代人来说。因此，我们当中许多人实际上把尼古丁当作一种感知中的情绪调节工具，也就不足为奇了。发表在《成瘾生物学》（Addiction Biology）杂志上的一项2019年研究通过观察压力如何扰乱吸烟者的大脑证明了这一点，这项研究的结果相当具有启发性和震撼性。研究人员给研究中的一些吸烟者注射了应激激素以模拟现实生活中的压力反应，然后让他们进入核磁共振扫描仪并执行记忆任务。通常情况下，有助于自我控制的大脑区域——你的前额叶皮层——会亮起
up to help you stay focused doing a task like this. But under stress, activity here was massively reduced. Then came the really interesting part. The smokers had to choose between completing the task for money or puffs of a cigarette, not even an entire cigarette. Those who were taking the stress hormones, they went for the cigarettes way more, even though they didn't report feeling more cravings. So basically stress didn't just make them want to smoke. It quietly kind of shut down the brain's ability to choose anything else, even like a cash reward. You're feeling stress. You're feeling stress. that is the first place your brain is going to go. And since reducing stress takes a priority in our mind,
来帮助你在执行这样的任务时保持专注。但在压力下，这里的活动大大减少。接下来是有趣的部分。吸烟者必须在完成任务以换取金钱或几口香烟（甚至不是整支烟）之间做出选择。那些注射了应激激素的人更多地选择了香烟，尽管他们并没有报告说感到更强烈的渴望。所以基本上压力不仅让他们想抽烟。它悄悄地关闭了大脑选择任何其他事物的能力，甚至是现金奖励。你感到了压力。你感到了压力。那是你大脑首先会去的地方。既然减轻压力在我们的脑海中占据优先地位，
of course, that is the habit that you're going to continue to choose, even when it's sometimes at the expense of doing something that's perhaps more productive. This can also, you know, crucially lead to a false sense of control over our stress and not just over our stress, but, you know, if you're going through a breakup over your sadness, if you're going through like a real identity change or identity shift, your sense of existential dread or your sense of just like general life stress. Nicotine often feels like it helps with these feelings. It gives you a real moment of calm.
当然，这将是你继续选择的习惯，即使有时是以牺牲做一些可能更具成效的事情为代价。这也会，至关重要的是，导致对我们压力的虚假控制感，不仅是对我们的压力，而且，如果你正在经历分手，是对你的悲伤，如果你正在经历真正的身份改变或身份转变，你的存在主义恐惧感或你对一般生活压力的普遍感觉。尼古丁往往让人觉得有助于缓解这些情绪。它给你带来真正的平静时刻。
It gives you a moment of focus, sometimes of peace in these situations. We can't deny that. But does it actually help with the stress in the long term? This short answer is no. It really doesn't. The immediate relief that you. may feel when you smoke or vape, it isn't genuine stress reduction. More often that relief comes from two things. The fact is, is that you're actually putting your body under more stress
它在这些情况下给你带来专注的时刻，有时甚至是平静。我们不能否认这一点。但它真的能在长期内帮助缓解压力吗？简短的回答是不会。它真的没有。当你吸烟或抽电子烟时你可能会感到的即时解脱，并不是真正的压力减轻。更多时候，这种解脱来自两件事。事实是，你实际上把你的身体置于更大的压力之下
because you are addicted to a substance and constantly going through like a miniature version of withdrawal from that substance unless you are constantly using it. And it could also be that it's not the nicotine that's helping you, it's the fact that you're taking a moment out of your day, or it's the fact that you have a sense of ritual that's reducing your stress. It's not actually the nicotine entirely. In reality, chronic nicotine use is actually associated with increased anxiety and stress over time. The study published back in 2001, so a little while ago, but still relevant, it actually found that teenagers who regularly smoke were sick and
因为你对一种物质上瘾，并不断经历该物质的微型戒断版本，除非你一直在使用它。这也可能是因为帮助你的不是尼古丁，而是你从一天中抽出片刻时间的事实，或者是你拥有减少压力的仪式感这一事实。其实并不完全是尼古丁。实际上，随着时间的推移，长期使用尼古丁实际上与焦虑和压力增加有关。早在2001年发表的一项研究——所以有一点时间了，但仍然相关——实际上发现经常吸烟的青少年生病了，并且
significantly more likely to report higher stress levels compared to those who had quit smoking. This is because the nicotine disrupts the brain's natural stress regulation systems, making you more prone to anxiety when you're not using it. The perceived control is a trick your brain plays on you because it wants the nicotine. You can kind of see how this cycle becomes really tricky to break, right? the more you use it, the more stress you feel when you can't use it, so the greater the pull towards the substance is. And the more singular your coping strategy becomes whereby a cigarette or nicotine is the only thing that you want. I think another element of nicotine addiction or
与那些已经戒烟的人相比，他们报告更高压力水平的可能性要显著得多。这是因为尼古丁破坏了大脑的自然压力调节系统，使你在不使用它时更容易产生焦虑。这种感知到的控制感是你大脑跟你开的一个玩笑，因为它渴望尼古丁。你可以看出这个循环变得多么难以打破，对吧？你用得越多，当你不能用它时你感到的压力就越大，因此对这种物质的吸引力就越大。你的应对策略变得越单一，以至于香烟或尼古丁成为你想要的唯一东西。我认为尼古丁成瘾的另一个因素，或者
nicotine usage really comes down to the fact that at different times and continuously, Smoking has been marketed and perceived as cool, as rebellious or like a symbol of being part of the in-group. This social dimension is actually a huge psychological hook, particularly when we're in our teenage years, but also when we're in our 20s. And you just really want to belong. You want to feel like, you know, you're part of a group, you're part of a crowd that you're aligned with people. We can think about this through looking at psychologist to Herbert Kelman's different types or levels of conformity, which he theorized and worked on in the 1950s. Basically, he came up with this theory of how we adjust our behavior to match those around us. And he can be applied everywhere.
尼古丁的使用实际上归结为这样一个事实：在不同的时间和持续不断的情况下，吸烟一直被营销和认为是酷的、叛逆的或者是成为内部群体一员的象征。这种社会维度实际上是一个巨大的心理钩子，特别是在我们的青少年时期，但也包括在我们二十多岁的时候。而你真的只是想融入。你希望感觉，你知道的，你是某个群体的一部分，你是你所认同的人群的一部分。我们可以通过审视心理学家赫伯特·凯尔曼（Herbert Kelman）在20世纪50年代提出并研究的不同类型或级别的遵从性来思考这一点。基本上，他提出了一个关于我们如何调整行为以匹配周围人的理论。这可以应用到各个地方。
Like this theory applies to cults. It applies to bullying. It applies to why we like certain artists, why we choose certain clients. why we choose certain clothes, it also can be applied to why we smoke. So the first level of conformity is compliance. This is when you publicly go along with the group's behavior, even if you don't privately agree with it because you want to gain rewards or avoid a sense of social punishment. So you pick up a vapor to party because everyone else is doing it. You have the cigarette outside because everyone else is outside. You don't want to be the only one inside. You're conforming to fit in.
就像这个理论适用于邪教一样。它适用于霸凌。它适用于为什么我们喜欢某些艺术家，为什么我们选择某些客户。为什么我们选择某些衣服，它也可以应用于为什么我们吸烟。所以遵从性的第一层是顺从（compliance）。这是当你公开顺从群体的行为时，即使你在私下并不同意它，因为你想获得奖励或避免社会惩罚感。所以你在派对上拿起电子烟，因为其他人都在这样做。你在外面抽烟，因为其他人都在外面。你不想成为唯一一个呆在里面的人。你在顺从以融入其中。
you're conforming to be accepted, but maybe at that point you're not truly enjoying it or liking it. Interestingly, compliance stops when there is no group pressure to conform. So you're not going to have a cigarette unless you're in the social situation. Next is identification. You conform because you like or respect the group or person and you want to maintain a desirable relationship with them. and you also want to be more like them at all times. So maybe in older sibling babes or like the cool girls in the locker room like all chew nicotine gum. You adopt the behavior because it strengthens your bond with the group at all times.
你顺从以被接受，但也许在那一刻你并没有真正享受它或喜欢它。有趣的是，当没有遵从的群体压力时，顺从就会停止。所以除非你身处社交场合，否则你不会抽烟。接下来是认同（identification）。你顺从是因为你喜欢或尊重该群体或个人，并且你想与他们保持令人满意的关系。而且你也希望在所有时间都更像他们。所以可能是一个年长的兄弟姐妹抽电子烟，或者像更衣室里很酷的女孩一样，都嚼尼古丁口香糖。你采纳这种行为是因为它在任何时候都加强了你与群体的联系。
You are probably performing the behavior even when they're not around. Or you're not getting pressured into it as much explicitly. Thirdly is internalization. This is the deepest level of conformity. and it happens when you actually come to privately accept the belief or the behavior as your own because you genuinely believe that it is beneficial, that it aligns with your persona, it aligns with your values. This happens with nicotine when, you know, you perhaps have been introduced through those other mechanisms and then you suddenly start to feel the biological and psychological pool yourself.
即使他们不在身边，你可能也在表现出这种行为。或者你没有受到那么多明确的压力。第三个是内化（internalization）。这是最高深一层的遵从。它发生在当你真正开始私下接受这种信念或行为作为你自己的信念或行为时，因为你真诚地认为它是有益的，它符合你的个性，它符合你的价值观。当尼古丁出现时，这种情况就会发生，你知道，你可能是通过那些其他机制被引入的，然后你突然开始自己感受到生物学和心理上的拉力。
And so it becomes integrated into how you view your life, you know, You believe that smoking makes you calmer. You believe that vaping helps you focus. You believe that, you know, it makes you look a certain way. Your habit has at that stage become deeply embedded into your self-perception. And it's also happening at the same time as a lot of underlying biological mechanisms. The reasons for doing a behavior changes over time. And it changes as your neurochemistry is changing in response to this highly addictive.
因此，它融入了你如何看待你的生活，你知道的，你相信吸烟能让你更冷静。你相信电子烟能帮你集中注意力。你相信，你知道的，它让你看起来有一种特定的样子。在这个阶段，你的习惯已经深深地嵌入到了你的自我感知中。而且它与许多潜在的生物学机制同时发生。一种行为的原因随着时间而改变。随着你的神经化学物质为了应对这种高度上瘾的物质而发生变化，它也在改变。
substance. We know that alongside this as well, so you're dealing with this biological component, the stress component, this social component, and then we have the marketing component. Tobacco and vaping industries, the tobacco and vaping industry, are incredibly good at what they do in terms of getting more people smoking, and they exploit these psychological vulnerabilities in very sophisticated insidious ways that often targets young people, often leverages social desirability and the desire for belonging. So we're going to talk about just how powerful these mechanisms are, but also how you can, I guess, act against them and maybe even escape the pool and the addiction to nicotine after this short break.
我们知道除此之外，还有，所以你正在处理这个生物学部分、压力部分、社交部分，然后我们有营销部分。烟草和电子烟行业，烟草和电子烟行业，在吸引更多人吸烟方面非常擅长，他们以非常复杂隐蔽的方式利用这些心理脆弱性，这些方式通常针对年轻人，通常利用社会合意性和对归属感的渴望。因此，在短暂的休息之后，我们将讨论这些机制有多么强大，以及你如何能够针对它们采取行动，甚至摆脱对尼古丁的拉力和成瘾。
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also a lot of people. and escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
2%。这是在有电梯的情况下选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、体能以及复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以抛开那些统治健康行业的、不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill?
我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。那是 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 上的 TWO percent，或者你在哪里收听播客都可以。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆（Little Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆有什么关系？
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed cracks.
好吧，你可以在 Look Back at it 播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何度过难关的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的访谈，畅谈80年代的可卡因。需要明确的是，84年对我的意义重大，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我愿意在某天谈论可卡因，但为了让大家知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，马克，这是我们第二次讨论可卡因了。
So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
所以我开始看到这里有一条贯穿线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你把话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look back at it。欢迎来到我的新播客《用艰难的方式学习》（Learn the Hard Way），我是主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine），瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross,
有时候，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，却仍然在追逐，并且不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们在看记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns），达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），
because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast,
因为你觉得在你活在世上时做一个好人很重要？你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正地做一个好人。和我，科尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客中，进行关于疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标的真实对话，
learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd, found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle
《用艰难的方式学习》。打开你的免费 iHeartRadio 应用。搜索 Learn the hard way 并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她故事中明显的前后矛盾。这开启了长达数年的法庭之战
to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
来证明真相。欧文斯女士，你曾两次篡改过这项特定的测试，对吧？我篡改测试是一次。这需要大批网络侦探出动来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through, the same thing. Greg Lespian and Michael Maranini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues,
另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·莱斯皮安（Greg Lespian）和迈克尔·马拉尼尼（Michael Maranini）。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《深陷爱河》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，
Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast
劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉面临欺诈指控。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。收听《深陷爱河》播客
on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Flavored vapes, sleek, designs, social media influences, and I guess also the widespread retail availability of nicotine products are all tactics designed to attract a new generation of users. A new generation that needs to replace the generation that used to smoke more traditionally. These designs and flavors, they have been cooked up.
在 iHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。水果味的电子烟、流线型的设计、社交媒体网红，我想还有尼古丁产品广泛的零售可得性，都是旨在吸引新一代用户的策略。新一代需要取代过去更传统地吸烟的那一代。这些设计和口味，它们是在实验室里炮制出来的，
up in a lab and they are often specifically engineered to appeal to younger novelty-seeking demographics, which is one of the reasons we're seeing such a growth in a younger audience taking up vaping. Another huge part of why vaping and nicotine is having a moment and rising, was its initial marketing as a healthy alternative to cigarettes or a safer way to quit smoking or even just a harmless recreational activity. This narrative was incredibly effective in capturing a more health-conscious generation that we found ourselves in. And the thing is, they weren't lying when they said that it was healthier.
并且通常经过专门设计，以吸引更年轻、寻求新鲜感的人群，这也是我们看到年轻观众开始吸电子烟的数量如此增长的原因之一。电子烟和尼古丁之所以大热并不断上升的另一个巨大原因，是它最初被营销为香烟的健康替代品，或者是一种更安全的戒烟方式，甚至只是一种无害的休闲活动。这种叙事在吸引我们所处的这一代更注重健康的人群方面非常有效。问题是，当他们说它更健康时，他们并没有撒谎。
It was healthier because there was no longitudinal studies proving otherwise. And because it was just a different way of consuming the same product with a different baseline of chemicals that didn't have as much research. search as cigarettes. They were really able to play the naive card. You know, it's, it's really crazy when you get into like the history of the tobacco industry and how its little grimy fingers are in literally everything, every, every industry that you can think of. I think public perception even now is often confused about the relative harms of vaping versus traditional cigarettes, with many of us wrongly believing vaping is harmless or security.
它更健康，因为没有纵向研究证明事实并非如此。而且因为这只是消费同一产品的一种不同方式，具有不同的化学成分基线，而这些成分的研究不像香烟那么多。他们真的能够打出天真无邪牌。你知道，当你真正了解烟草工业的历史，以及它那肮脏的小手如何伸进字面上的每一个行业、你能想到的每一个行业时，这真的很疯狂。我认为即使在现在，公众对电子烟与传统香烟的相对危害的认知往往仍然很混乱，我们许多人错误地认为电子烟是无害的，或者安全性
significantly less harmful than it actually is. You know, it tastes like blueberries. Like, how could this possibly be unhealthy for me? And this deliberate blurring of the lines is a powerful marketing tool. It's leveraging misinformation to normalize and popularize usage. It's burying research papers. It's burying people who say something against this product by, you know, undermining their credibility or by getting paying off another group of researchers or another university
比实际情况要高得多。你知道，它尝起来像蓝莓。这怎么可能对我不健康呢？这种故意模糊界限的做法是一种强大的营销工具。它利用虚假信息来使使用行为正常化和普及化。它压制研究论文。它通过破坏发表反对该产品意见的人的信誉，或者收买另一组研究人员或另一所大学来压制他们。
to write a positive paper you know they could shell out millions of dollars to get the results they want for this product they're trying to make money off of and here's where this is really really concerning is that like vaping is actually and has been found to be more addictive than traditional cigarettes and it has people consuming higher dosages and more nicotine than they would if they had been smoking, especially for people who were trying to quit smoking. They've done studies comparing the level of nicotine, I guess the levels of nicotine they were inhaling slash consuming before when they were smoking versus now when they're vaping and it's higher. Some individuals, and I know this is a bit more anecdotal, but I've spoken to people who are,
来写一篇积极的论文，你知道的，他们可以砸下数百万美元来为这个他们试图从中赚钱的产品获得他们想要的结果。而这里真正令人担忧的地方在于，电子烟实际上被发现比传统香烟更容易让人上瘾，并且让人们消费更高剂量的尼古丁，比他们以前吸烟时消耗的尼古丁还要多，特别是对于那些试图戒烟的人来说。他们做过研究，比较了以前吸烟时吸入/消耗的尼古丁水平与现在抽电子烟时的尼古丁水平，结果发现更高。有些人，我知道这有点偏向经验之谈，但我曾和一些人交谈过，他们是，
finding it so hard to quit vaping that they have gone back to traditional cigarettes as a perceived stepping stone towards quitting nicotine in general, but vaping mainly. Like they find that cigarettes and their use of cigarettes are actually easier to control because you can't do it in public spaces as easily. You can't or slash you don't want to smoke in your home or in your car or in front of people. So there's more of a barrier to constant usage. If you want some evidence that this is actually happening or that it's not just observational, there was one 2020 study I found from researchers at the University of Southern California, which basically analyzed over 3,000 Twitter posts looking at common themes related to quitting Jewel, the vape brand. It's kind of gone a little bit
发现戒电子烟太难了，以至于他们又回到了传统香烟，认为这是彻底戒掉尼古丁（主要是电子烟）的一个过渡。他们发现香烟其实更容易控制，因为你不能在公共场所那么容易地抽烟。你不能或者说你不想在家里、车里或当着别人的面抽烟。因此，持续使用的门槛更高了。如果你想要证据证明这确实在发生，而不仅仅是观察到的现象，我发现了一项2020年南加州大学研究人员的研究，该研究基本上分析了3000多条推文，探讨了与戒掉电子烟品牌JUEL相关的常见主题。现在它可能有点
out of style now, but not only were over a quarter of the posts talking about different methods to quit using Jewel. But there was quite a big proportion of them joking about how they were going to try picking up smoking cigarettes to do so. I also saw a recent Reddit thread from someone basically conducting an experiment on themselves by going back to cigarettes and attempts to quit vaping to see if it was going to be successful. They tried all these other things. They couldn't do it. You know, even just a quick look over the other comments that followed that showed that this was not a unique situation. A lot of people were saying that the strength and the availability of over-the-counter vapes
过时了，但不仅有超过四分之一的推文在讨论戒掉JUEL的不同方法，而且很大一部分推文都在开玩笑说他们要尝试抽香烟来达到这个目的。我还看到最近的一个Reddit帖子，有人基本上通过回到香烟来对自己进行实验，试图戒掉电子烟，看看是否会成功。他们尝试了所有其他方法，但都失败了。你知道，只要快速浏览一下随后的其他评论，就会发现这并非个例。许多人表示，非处方电子烟的强度和可获得性
and the social acceptance and the fact that they taste great and they don't smell as terrible has made them even more dependent on nicotine than they ever were before. The initial promise of vaping that it was a healthier alternative, that it was going to help people, I think it's just simply created a new complex addiction pathway. Here's another element of this that I just considered as well. I need to introduce this. Our brains are really clever at making us believe we don't have a problem. So now we're also phasing our own minds, right? Our brains have this really great way of convincing us that we could quit at any time,
以及社会的接受度，加上它们味道极佳且气味没那么难闻，让他们对尼古丁的依赖比以往任何时候都深。电子烟最初的承诺是它是一个更健康的替代品，它能帮助人们，但我认为它只是创造了一条新的、复杂的成瘾途径。这里还有另一个我刚刚想到的因素。我需要引入这一点。我们的大脑非常聪明，能让我们相信我们没有问题。所以现在我们也在欺骗我们自己的思想，对吧？我们的大脑有一种非常厉害的方式来说服我们随时都可以戒掉，
that we're not smoking as much as we think we are, that, you know, we have it under control as a way to keep us hooked because it does make us feel good. even when rationally we know that we're kind of lying to ourselves. I had this friend who used to smoke five cigarettes a day, but only five. Like she would only have five cigarettes a day. And she would always say, like, when I turn 25, I'm going to quit. And one day we got approached by these, like, marketing people on the street doing a survey when we were at uni. And they came up to us and they were like, do you, do either of you guys smoke?
我们抽得没有想象的那么多，你知道的，我们一切尽在掌握，以此来让我们继续上瘾，因为它确实让我们感觉良好。即使我们在理性上知道我们是在对自己撒谎。我有个朋友以前一天抽五根烟，但也仅此而已。就像她一天只抽五根烟。她总是说，等我25岁了，我就戒烟。有一天，我们在上大学时，街上有做调查的市场营销人员向我们走来。他们走过来对我们说，你们两个有人抽烟吗？
We're conducting some research. And she said no. She was like, no, I don't. And she fully, like, afterwards, I asked her, I was like, why did you say no? Like, you do smoke. And she was like, oh, no, no, no. Like, I don't smoke because I only smoke five a day or, and I only smoke them when I'm out. And I only smoke them on weekends or like when I'm drinking, which back then we were in college.
我们在做一些研究。她说没有。她说，不，我不抽。后来我问她，为什么说不抽？你明明抽烟啊。她就说，哦，不，不，不。我不抽烟，因为我一天只抽五根，或者，我只在出门时抽。我只在周末或喝酒时抽，那时候我们在上大学。
So we were drinking all the time. But she was like, no, there was this cognitive dissonance. I don't smoke. I'm not a smoker, even though she had literally had one five minutes before. Cognitive dissonance is a powerful psychological discomfort we feel when our beliefs, attitudes or behaviors clash. In the context of nicotine, the clash is very glaring and that's a great example of it right there.
所以我们经常喝酒。但她说，不，这里存在一种认知失调。我不抽烟。我不是烟民，尽管她五分钟前才刚抽过一根。认知失调是我们当信念、态度或行为发生冲突时感到的强烈心理不适。在尼古丁的背景下，这种冲突非常明显，这正是一个很好的例子。
The deeply held belief of, I know that smoking and vaping is bad for my health, goes up against the fact that we are continuing to smoke and vape. this creates an internal tension, kind of mental unease where two things can't be true. Like those two things that we know this is bad for us, we know we care about our health, and yet we continue to do it. They can't all exist at once without making us uncomfortable. And so our brain does a few things to kind of reduce the discomfort and kind of rationalize our behavior or lie to us.
根深蒂固的信念——“我知道吸烟和电子烟对我的健康有害”——与我们继续吸烟和抽电子烟的事实相碰撞。这产生了一种内部紧张感，一种心理上的不安，因为两件矛盾的事不能同时为真。比如这两件事：我们知道这对我们有害，我们知道我们在乎健康，然而我们却继续这样做。这些不可能同时存在而不让我们感到不舒服。因此，大脑会做一些事情来减轻这种不适，合理化我们的行为，或者对自己撒谎。
So, for example, we might minimize the harm it's causing and say, things like, oh, it's actually not that bad. Like, oh, my grandma, she smoked a pack a day and she never got cancer. Like, this is, this is a lie. Some people, it just doesn't hurt some people. We might think, everyone does it. So I won't be alone in dealing with the health consequences. So surely, again, like, this isn't going to hurt me. And if it does, it will hurt other people as well. We might convince ourselves that we aren't actually smokers, you know, a smoker is someone who smokes more than five cigarettes or who smokes, you know, a pack a day. And if I'm not smoking that much, well, then I'm not a smoker. We might focus on the perceived benefits. You know, well, it helps me
所以，举个例子，我们可能会尽量淡化它造成的危害，说一些这样的话：“其实没那么糟。比如，我奶奶一天抽一包烟，她从来没得过癌症。”这简直是谎言。有些人的身体就是不会因此受损。我们可能会想：“大家都这么做。所以我不会独自承担健康的后果。所以当然了，这不会伤害我。如果真的伤害了，别人也会受影响。”我们可能会说服自己，我们其实不是烟民，你知道的，烟民是指一天抽五支以上或者抽一包烟的人。如果我没抽那么多，那我自然就不是烟民。我们可能会关注那些想象中的好处。你知道的，这能帮我
relax and de-stress. And stress is more, stress is more dangerous than smoking. So actually, I'm doing myself a favor. We might also place it on external factors, like, well, I'm going through a breakup, or my job is stressful right now, or everyone around me is smoking. so I have to. It's not about me that's making the choice. It's my circumstances. And then the biggest one is the promise of future action. So it's okay to do this right now because I know I'm going to quit when I'm 25. I know I'm going to quit after this big exam, after this holiday. I know I'm going to quit, you know, when I feel ready and that I could do that at any time, just that I don't actually have a problem right now. These rationalizations are basically live.
放松和减压。而压力比吸烟更危险。所以实际上，我是在帮自己。我们还可能会归咎于外部因素，比如，我正在经历失恋，或者我现在的压力很大，或者我周围的人都在抽烟，所以我不得不抽。这不是我作出的选择，而是我的环境造成的。然后，最大的一点就是对未来行动的承诺。所以现在这样做没关系，因为我知道我25岁时会戒烟。我知道我会在这次大考后、这次假期后戒烟。我知道我会戒烟，你知道的，当我准备好的时候，我随时都可以做到，只是我现在真的没有问题。这些合理化其实就是谎言，
often unconscious lies we tell ourselves to maintain a consistent self-image and to again reduce that internal psychological discomfort. They become very powerful mental barriers, making it easier to keep using nicotine even in the face of overwhelming evidence that it's going to harm us. Quitting nicotine is notoriously difficult precisely because it has, and it is known as a multi-layered addiction. It's physical, it's psychological, it's social, it's psychological, it's social. it's behavioral, it's cognitive, it's so, it's just, it's cultural, there's so many levels to this. It's not just breaking one chain, it's breaking many, many intricately woven ones that want to keep you locked in on this behavior. Again, nicotine as it's pure, in a pure form is not actually bad for you.
往往是我们为了保持一致的自我形象而对自己撒的无意识谎言，目的同样是减少内部的心理不适。它们变成了非常强大的精神障碍，让我们更容易继续使用尼古丁，即使面对压倒性的证据证明它会伤害我们。戒除尼古丁出了名的困难，正是因为它是一种多层面的成瘾。它是生理上的，是心理上的，是社会的，是心理上的，是社会的，是行为上的，是认知的，是文化的，这里面有太多层面了。这不仅仅是斩断一条链条，而是斩断许多紧密交织的链条，它们想把你牢牢锁定在这种行为中。再次强调，纯净形式的尼古丁实际上对你并无害处。
There are nicotonic receptors in all of our brains. It is acting on very positive chemicals in our brain that are helpful. it's what it comes in that is so bad for us. The intense discomfort of withdrawal symptoms as well, that is a massive barrier and that is why we continue to consume what we know as a bad and harmful product. Even when we don't always want to, your body genuinely feels unwell. The quickest way to relieve that is more nicotine. Of course, then it becomes deeply entwined as well with that emotional regulation. we were talking about. For long-term users as well, nicotine can also become deeply embedded in their
我们的大脑中都有尼古丁受体。它作用于我们大脑中非常积极且有益的化学物质。真正对我们有害的是它所附带的载体。戒断症状带来的强烈不适也是一个巨大的障碍，这就是为什么我们继续消费这种我们明知糟糕且有害的产品。即使我们并不总是想这样，你的身体也确实会感到不适。缓解这一状况最快的方法就是摄入更多尼古丁。当然，它随后也会与我们讨论过的情绪调节深度交织在一起。对于长期使用者来说，尼古丁也可能深深植根于他们的
personal and social identity. I am a smoker. I am a vapour. This is part of my look. Letting go of that identity can feel like losing a part of yourself and that's not a silly thing. That's not a small thing either. And if all your friends and all your family still uses nicotine, again, the social pressure, direct or indirect, the fear of missing out on shared rituals. can make it incredibly challenging. So how do we actually start to unlearn what is simply at its core, just a bad habit that is held up by a lot of underlying mechanisms we've already spoken about? How do we unlearn the bad habit?
个人和社会认同中。我是一个烟民。我是一个电子烟客。这是我外表的一部分。放手这种认同感会感觉像是失去了自己的一部分，这并不是一件傻事。这也不是一件小事。如果你的所有朋友和家人都还在使用尼古丁，那么来自直接或间接的社会压力，以及害怕错过共同社交仪式的恐惧，会带来巨大的挑战。那么，我们究竟该如何开始戒除这个本质上只是一个坏习惯的东西呢？这个习惯由我们已经讨论过的许多潜在机制所支撑。我们该如何戒除这个坏习惯？
So we need to target all three levels of this addiction, the physical, the psychological, and the behavioral. And it's a conscious act of reprogramming your brain and your daily life, to respond differently to the triggers or, I don't know, I guess, yeah, the triggers is the best word, your triggers for using nicotine. Initially, breaking the physical cycle is really crucial. Approaches such as nicotine replacement therapy, using patches, gums, lozenges, inhalers, whatever it is, can really reduce physical withdrawal symptoms, giving you the psychological space to focus on
所以我们需要针对这种成瘾的三个层面：生理、心理和行为。这是一个有意识的过程，旨在重新编程你的大脑和日常生活，以对触发因素做出不同的反应，或者，我不知道，我想是的，用“触发因素”这个词最好，也就是你使用尼古丁的触发因素。最初，打破生理循环至关重要。诸如尼古丁替代疗法等方法——使用贴片、口香糖、锭剂、吸入器，无论是什么——都可以真正减轻生理戒断症状，为你提供心理空间去关注
the more cognitive and behavioral aspects. This helps your body kind of wean off the physical dependency and lessen the physical cues that might tell you that you need to vape or need a cigarette. This might take you a couple of times because, you know, there are so many other things that are going to be pulling you back. That's okay. Every time that you try is still a win in my mind.
更深层的认知和行为方面。这有助于你的身体逐渐摆脱生理依赖，并减少那些暗示你需要电子烟或香烟的生理信号。这可能需要你尝试好几次，因为你知道，还有很多其他因素会把你拉回老路。没关系。在我看来，你每一次的尝试都是一次胜利。
even if you end up going back, that's still a couple of days that you gave your lungs a break or that you, you know, had a bit of space just to like analyze what was really causing this behavior. So however many times it takes, once you get a hold of the physical triggers, you can then start to identify and disrupt the behavioral triggers. The first step to this is, of course, self-awareness. I know it's going to sound so simple, but really pay attention to when and why you want to use nicotine. what are your most common psychological triggers is it certain specific times of the day certain specific emotions like sadness like dread like stress like anxiety um is it particular places social
即使你最后又复吸了，那也依然是你让肺部休息了几天，或者你拥有了一点空间去分析到底是什么真正导致了这种行为。因此，无论需要尝试多少次，一旦你控制了生理触发因素，你就可以开始识别并打破行为触发因素。这第一步当然是自我觉察。我知道这听起来很简单，但请真正留意你何时以及为何想要使用尼古丁。你最常见的心理触发因素是什么？是一天中的某些特定时间？某些特定的情绪，比如悲伤、恐惧、压力、焦虑？嗯，是特定的地点、社交
situations even certain objects like when you're on your phone just take a notice of when you have that overwhelming feeling of like i need a cigarette right now or i need to vape right now You can then try to temporarily avoid strong triggers if possible by just asking yourself to ignore it for a minute. For a minute and then a minute and 15 seconds and then just go by the seconds. I always think of that Kimmy Schmidt, I think it's Kimmy Schmidt quote that's like, you can do anything for 30 seconds. You can avoid smoking, you can avoid vaping for just 30 seconds. and then another 30 seconds. More importantly, though, actively develop and practice healthy replacement behaviors for those triggers.
场合，甚至是某些特定的物品，比如当你在看手机时？只需留意当你产生那种“我现在极需要一根烟”或“我现在的确需要抽电子烟”的强烈感觉时的时刻。如果可能的话，你可以通过告诉自己忽略它一分钟，来暂时避开强烈的触发因素。先坚持一分钟，然后是一分钟十五秒，然后按秒来算。我总会想起金米·施密特的那句话，我觉得那是金米·施密特的名言，大意是：你可以坚持任何事情30秒。你可以忍住不抽烟，可以忍住不抽电子烟仅仅30秒，
So we talked about the physical replacements, but if you habitually smoke and vape with your morning coffee or when you're stressed or whatever it is, try and replace that behavior with something else so you still have the ritual. So when you are like having your morning coffee, instead of vaping. try and like just journal have a pen in your fingers instead if you find yourself vaping when you're at work because you're distracted or you're bored get some gum start chewing gum like that's i know it sounds small but you've got to like almost confuse your brain and be like this is what we used to do and this feels remarkably similar it's almost 90% there but like the 10% that's not
然后再坚持30秒。不过，更重要的是，要为这些触发因素积极开发和实践健康的替代行为。所以我们讨论了生理替代品，但如果你习惯在早晨喝咖啡时、或者感到压力大时抽烟或抽电子烟，无论是什么情况，试着用其他东西来取代那种行为，这样你依然保留了那种仪式感。所以当你在喝早晨的咖啡时，与其抽电子烟，不如试着写写日记，如果你发现自己工作时因为分心或无聊而抽电子烟，那就嚼口香糖，开始嚼口香糖。我知道这听起来微不足道，但你几乎需要迷惑你的大脑，告诉它：“这就是我们以前做的，这感觉非常相似，几乎有90%像，至于那剩下的10%不一样的地方，
there like we can just hopefully ignore that and hopefully feel like this is close enough. You know, if you used to take smoke breaks at work when you got stressed, take a five minute walk around the block instead. Even pair this like walking around with buying yourself a snack or buying yourself a treat. So you're getting that little dopamine boost whilst replacing the thing you're getting a reward from. I also think setting a goal that you could only do if you are not to smoking, something you really want to do is really, really amazing. So, for example, there are people who, like, have kids and they think, well, I want to be able to do this with my children and I won't be able to do that if I keep smoking. That's a great motivator.
我们可以试着忽略它，并希望这已经足够接近了。”你知道，如果你以前习惯在工作压力大时去抽烟休息，那就改成绕着街区散步五分钟。甚至可以把这种散步和给自己买个零食或犒劳自己结合起来。这样你就能获得一点多巴胺的提升，同时又替代了那个能给你带来奖励的事情。我也认为，设定一个只有在你不吸烟时才能达成的目标——一件你非常想做的事——真的非常非常棒。例如，有些人有孩子，他们会想：“嗯，我想和我的孩子一起做这件事，如果我继续抽烟，我就做不到了。”这是一个很好的动力。
Start training for, like, some kind of endurance race or trying to get fitter or trying to do something that you just can't do if you're smoking. Even, like, long haul flights, if you're really addicted. You obviously can't smoke or vape on a plane and maybe that's holding you back. What's something that, you know, you could only do if this product was no longer in your life. Since nicotine often serves as a physical and emotional crutch as well, we need to cultivate healthier ways to manage stress and boredom or anger or sadness or whatever it is. You know, the thing is, is that I can't tell you what that strategy is going to be for you because it's actually just like an entirely personal preference. For some people it's exercise. For some
开始为某种耐力赛进行训练，或者努力变得更健康，或者尝试做一些你在吸烟时绝对做不到的事情。甚至像长途飞行，如果你烟瘾很重。你显然不能在飞机上抽烟或抽电子烟，也许这正限制了你。有什么事情是你只有在这个产品彻底离开你的生活后才能做到的呢？由于尼古丁通常既是生理上的拐杖，也是情感上的拐杖，我们需要培养更健康的方法来管理压力、无聊、愤怒、悲伤或任何情绪。你知道，问题在于，我无法告诉你哪种策略最适合你，因为这实际上完全是个人的偏好。对某些人来说是运动。对某些
people it's meditation. For some people it's like physical like hobbies that involve your hands like knitting like coloring in like Sudoku. It's talking to a friend. Maybe it's just therapy. The goal here is to replace an unhealthy coping mechanism because smoking is a coping mechanism with a beneficial one because we know we also know that our brain likes to rationalize our behaviors as as we just spoke about, it's also important to try and restructure these as well. Actively challenge those lies and rationalizations and false beliefs with the truth. You know, for example, we might tell ourselves that nicotine helps me de-stress. This could be restructured to something like nicotine relieves withdrawal, which feels like
人来说是冥想。对某些人来说是动手的手工爱好，比如织毛衣、填色、数独。是和朋友聊天。也许只是进行心理治疗。这里的目标是取代一种不健康的应对机制——因为吸烟是一种应对机制——换成一个有益的机制。既然我们也知道大脑喜欢像我们刚才说的那样合理化我们的行为，那么尝试重构这些认知也很重要。用事实积极挑战那些谎言、合理化和错误的信念。你知道，比如，我们可能会告诉自己“尼古丁帮我减压”。这可以被重构为诸如“尼古丁缓解了戒断反应，这感觉像是
de-stressing, but in fact, I know my overall anxiety is going to increase long-term. you know we might be saying to ourselves oh but i'm not really a smoker maybe you could say instead a smoker is someone who smokes and what am i currently doing i'm smoking so if i don't know admire the identity of a smoker if i don't see this is who i am um i have to acknowledge that it is who i am and that i'm in like i'm tied up with those things and those parts of this activity that I don't find admirable. What does that say about my self-conceptive concept? Just really question the deceptive narratives your brain tells you and call it out for being sneaky. I think under everything, a belief and an actual desire and your own ability to quit is also
减压，但实际上，我知道我的总体焦虑长期来看会增加”。你知道，我们可能会对自己说：“哦，但我其实不是个烟民。”也许你可以反过来想：“烟民就是吸烟的人，而我现在在做什么？我在吸烟。所以如果我不认同烟民的身份，如果我不认为这就是我，我必须承认这确实是我，我与这些活动中那些我并不欣赏的部分纠缠在一起。”这说明了我的自我概念是什么？去质疑大脑告诉你的那些欺骗性叙事，并指出它的鬼祟之处。我认为在这一切的基础之上，信念、真正的渴望以及你自身的戒烟能力同样
super important. No one can quit unless they actually want to and unless they actually believe they can. You can give people 100,000 tips and tricks to stop vaping, but unless you want to, want to do it, which I assume you do considering you're listening to this episode, you won't. So think about your why. There is something calling you to want to quit or to reconsider this relationship. Is it because you want to live a long and healthy life? Is it because you want to complete some kind of fitness goal? Is it because you're starting to realize that this habit is actually really uncool and that people are judging you? I think at times when you are doubting your ability and whether this is the right choice, just returning to this why really helps
超级重要。没有人能戒烟，除非他们真心想戒，并且真心相信自己能做到。你可以给人们十万个戒烟的小贴士和小技巧，但除非你打心底里想戒——我假设既然你在听这一集，你确实想戒——否则你不会成功的。所以，想想你的“为什么”。有什么东西在召唤你想要戒烟或重新审视这段关系吗？是因为你想过上长寿健康的生活吗？是因为你想完成某种健身目标吗？是因为你开始意识到这个习惯其实很不酷，别人都在评判你吗？我想，每当你怀疑自己的能力以及这是否是正确的选择时，回归这个“为什么”真的能帮你
anchor you in that personal drive you have for quitting. On the back of that, I know we've kind of introduced this in small dosages, but it's so helpful just to set small achievable goals. For example, like I said, just going 30 seconds or an hour without trying just like one smoke-free day rather than just going cold turkey. I know a lot of people say go cold turkey. I still think that like every small thing, every small positive move in the right direction, every time you show yourself that you can,
锚定内心戒烟的个人动力。在此基础上，我知道我们已经以小剂量的方式引入了这一点，但设定小的、可实现的目标真的非常有用。例如，就像我说的，仅仅坚持30秒或一个小时不抽烟，尝试哪怕仅仅一个无烟日，而不是一下子彻底戒掉。我知道很多人说要“一次性彻底戒掉”。但我仍然认为，每一个微小的举动、朝着正确方向的每一个微小积极改变、每一次向自己证明你能做到，
even if it's just for smaller and smaller and then larger and larger increments of time, the more you build self-trust, self-efficacy, the more you see that like your life is not empty without this substance. As we said earlier, you know, this isn't necessarily a quick fix. It might not have you quitting in the moment, but it is a worthwhile interruption to the addiction cycle. Here's a crucial, compassionate truth. Relapse is a common part
哪怕时间越来越短，然后越来越长，你建立的自我信任和自我效能感就会越多，你会发现没有这种物质你的生活并非一片空白。正如我们之前所说，这不一定是一个快速见效的方案。它可能不会让你当场戒烟，但它是对成瘾循环的一次有价值的打断。这里有一个至关重要的、充满同情心的真相：复发是很多很多人的戒烟旅程中很常见的一部分。
of the quitting journey for many, many people. It is not a sign of failure. Research and clinical guidelines show that most smokers make multiple attempts sometimes upwards of 15 before achieving long-term abstinence. Seeing it as a setback rather than a full defeat, seeing this as part of the journey that's going to get you to fully quit is crucial for success. If you relapse, please resist the urge for self-criticism or shame because it only makes it harder to get back on track. When you're like, well, I can't believe I did this, you know, again, that part of your brain that wants to protect your self-esteem is going to say something like, well, obviously this is a sign that we're not strong enough and so we could we should keep doing this. Obviously this is a sign that this is
这并不是失败的信号。研究和临床指南表明，大多数吸烟者都会多次尝试，有时甚至超过15次，才能实现长期戒断。将复发视为暂时的挫折而非彻底的失败，将这视为带你走向彻底戒烟的旅程的一部分，对成功至关重要。如果你复发了，请克制住自我批评或羞耻感的冲动，因为这只会让回到正轨变得更加困难。当你心里想“天哪，我真不敢相信我居然又这样了”时，你知道的，你大脑中想要保护自尊的那部分就会说：“很显然，这说明我们还不够坚强，所以我们应该继续抽下去。很显然，这说明这就是
part of who we are and that we need this so we should keep doing it. This keeps you stranded in the behavioral loop, in the compulsion. It's so easy to throw in the towel at times like this, but don't let one lapse turn into a full-blown relapse. Immediately try and get yourself to recommit to quitting. Adjust your strategy. This is an important learning. There's important lesson as to what drove you to relapse. Like there is a trigger there that was ignored. There was compulsion there that was just too hard to overcome. What is it?
我们的一部分，我们需要它，所以我们应该继续抽。”这会让你滞留在行为回路和强迫中。在这样的时刻很容易自暴自弃，但不要让一次偶犯变成全面的复发。立即尝试让自己重新承诺戒烟。调整你的策略。这是一个重要的教训。关于是什么驱使你复发，这里有一个重要的教训。那就是有一个被忽视的触发因素。有一个难以克服的强迫心理。那到底是什么？
How can you gain mastery over that the next time? And finally, this is the biggest tip I have for, I think, any kind of quitting of any kind of behavior that you don't like. Tell your friends. Tell your family. Tell the people you are around the most that this is something you want to do. that this is something that you are committed to doing because it gives you accountability.
下次你该如何掌控它呢？最后，这是我对于戒除任何你不喜欢的行为提出的最大的建议。告诉你的朋友。告诉你的家人。告诉你身边最亲近的人，这是你想做的事。这是你承诺要做的事，因为这能给你带来责任感。
If you say to your friends, I really want to quit smoking, I just feel like there's more of a barrier or a sense of, you know, judgment sometimes if you're not, especially friends who don't smoke or friends who don't vape. Of course, if you tell your friends who do smoke, like, I'm going to quit, you know, sometimes they don't want you to quit because it continues to validate that they're going to be okay.
如果你对朋友说：“我真的很想戒烟，”你会发现，如果你不抽烟，尤其是在面对不抽烟或不吸电子烟的朋友时，有时会感受到更多的阻力或评判感。当然，如果你对那些也抽烟的朋友说“我要戒烟”，有时他们并不希望你戒烟，因为这会继续证明他们自己这样做也是没问题的。
So just tell people who you know have opinions on this habit, who will encourage you and help you stay kind of loyal to your goal. It can be such an important form of extrinsic motivation. So I think that's all we have time for. I hope that this episode informed you. I hope that you learned something. I hope that you understand nicotine as a substance more, but also the addiction behind it more as well. and I hope you have compassion and empathy for yourself, but also for other people who are struggling with this. I know, like, nicotine usage is on the rise. That's very scary, but I don't think that, like, all hope is lost.
所以，只需告诉那些你了解对这个习惯有看法、会鼓励你并帮助你忠于目标的人。这可以成为一种非常重要的外在动机。我想这就是我们今天节目的全部时间了。希望这一集对你有所启发。希望你学到了一些东西。希望你对尼古丁这种物质以及它背后的成瘾机制有了更多的了解，我也希望你能对自己、以及对其他正在与此抗争的人抱有同情和同理心。我知道，尼古丁的使用率正在上升。这非常可怕，但我并不认为一切希望都破灭了。
And I know it's, like, dark times at the moment. Sometimes it feels like a cigarette or whatever it is, is the only hope. But I promise it's not. And I promise that, yeah, one day you'll be able to be like, wow, I can't believe I smoked back then. Oh, yeah, I used to be a smoker. But you're not anymore. So that's my wish for you. If you enjoyed this episode, share it with a friend who you think might need to hear it. Maybe your friend who is secretly smoking but won't tell anyone or like my friend who said she wasn't a smoker because she smoked only five cigarettes a day, whoever it is who needs to hear this. Share a link with them.
我知道目前的时期很黑暗。有时感觉一支烟或其他什么东西是唯一的希望。但我向你保证，并不是。我向你保证，是的，有一天你会忍不住说：“哇，真不敢相信我当年还抽过烟。哦，对，我以前是个烟民。”但你现在已经不是了。这就是我对你的祝福。如果你喜欢这一集，请把它分享给你认为可能需要听的朋友。也许是那个偷偷抽烟却不告诉任何人的朋友，或者像我的朋友那样说自己不是烟民因为一天只抽五根烟，无论谁需要听到这些。把链接分享给他们。
Make sure that you are following along wherever you are listening and give a five-star review if you feel called to do so. And hey, if you're still here, what should our emoji be? leave, I don't want to make it like a cigarette emoji because that's too basic. Leave a little puff of smoke emoji down below so I know that you made it this far. Thanks for listening to the end. That's so nice of you. I appreciate that so much.
确保在你收听的任何地方关注我们，如果你愿意，请留下五星好评。嘿，如果你还在听，我们的表情符号应该是什么？离开，我不想用香烟的表情符号，因为那太基础了。在下方留下一个小烟团的表情符号，让我知道你听到了这里。感谢收听到底。你太好了，我非常感激。
But until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle with yourself. You've got this. We will talk very, very soon. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
但直到下一次，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点。你一定能行的。我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带你超越主导健康行业的那些不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim?
我们曾经真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些苦难，你将成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的“TWO percent”。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？
you can find out on The Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but yeah, yeah, literally. But just so you all know.
你可以在《The Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利斯。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集请来了马克·拉蒙特·希尔，大谈80年代的可卡因。需要澄清的是，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以谈论可卡因，真的，真的是这样。但为了让大家知道。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了。所以我开始看出这其中有一条主线。我们现在还讨论了艾滋病。谢谢你把话说完。我认为没有哪个年份对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase
在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《迎难而上》（Learn the Hard Way），我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将带上我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入这场追逐，
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person
以至于我们没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。我们甚至不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是盯着记分牌。生活变成了输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要吗？
while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing,
你是一个好人，仅仅是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。这是两种不同层面的信任。我希望你纯粹只是因为想做一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《迎难而上》中，就治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标展开真实的对话。
growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search, learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal.
打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前“单身汉”明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。
The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistency in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
随后的家事法庭听证会揭示了她故事中显而易见的矛盾之处。这拉开了长达数年的法庭之战，只为证明真相。你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试，对吧？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男子。
Greg Alesspian and Michael Marincini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. this is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news
格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马林奇尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，突发新闻
at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs
来自马里科帕县，劳拉·欧文斯已被以欺诈罪起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立抗压能力的科学。经历一些苦难，你将成为一个
when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side
更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。即“TWO%”。在I-HartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。在《Look Back at a》播客中，对于1979年来说，那对我是一个重大的时刻。84年对我意义重大。
a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the I-HartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at a podcast, For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利斯。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。那真是个疯狂的年份。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year.
我认为没有哪个年份对黑人来说更重要了。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师和主持人基尔·盖恩斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在其他地方根本无法安全进行的坦诚对话，但在这里你是在与一位懂行的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着盔甲？
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? Listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and hosts Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with.
这向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着仅仅因为你有这种能力，你就必须表现出来。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试，对吧？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男子。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
格雷格·吉利斯皮和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是“Love Trapped”。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
这是一个IHeart播客。真人保证。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一个 iHeart 播客。真人保证。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。